The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today what
we're going to do
is finish off our discussion
about oscillators.
In particular, we're going to
talk about alternative designs
for oscillators.
So rather than having
these loops that
are purely composed of
negative interactions,
negative feedback,
instead we're going
to talk about cases where you
have both positive and negative
interactions.
So in using this kind of
combined network structure,
you can generate what
are known as relaxation
oscillators, which have some
really wonderful properties.
In particular you can get
more robust oscillations,
relative to the parameters.
But also the oscillations
become tunable,
i.e. you can change
the frequency,
without compromising, for
example, the amplitude
of the oscillations.
So for both natural and
synthetic oscillators
these so-called
are perhaps the way to go.
And then we're
going to transition
to more of the global structure
of some these networks
in the context of transcription
networks within cells.
And discuss this paper
that you guys just
read, the Barabasi paper, which
is one of the world's most
cited papers, I think.
And then after thinking about
this global structure, of how
you might be able to generate
these so-called power law
structures, we're going
to look a little bit more
in detail to try to understand
something about these network
motifs.
We've already talked
about them a little bit
in the context of
auto regulatory loops,
but now we'll talk about
them in a little bit more
generality, in particular in the
context of feed forward loops.
And then on Thursday
we will get into some
of the possible beneficial
features of feed forward loops.
On Thursday we talked
about the repressilator.
So if you have x
inhibiting y inhibiting z
coming back and
inhibiting x, that it's
reasonable to expect that it
might generate oscillations.
And indeed in the Elowitz
paper that we read,
such a synthetic circuit did
indeed generate oscillations,
but there were perhaps a
few problems there, right?
So one is that only
about 40% of the cells
actually oscillated,
who knows why not.
But also there
were other problems
that the oscillations
seemed rather noisy,
there was relatively
rapid desyncronization.
Moreover, if you go and you
ask, well is it possible,
or how easy would be to change
the period of the oscillations
just by changing something
like the degradation rate, what
you'll find is that the
oscillations are not
very tunable.
So I'll say the period, or the
frequency, is not very tunable,
and indeed this is a general
feature of oscillatory networks
that have purely
negative interactions.
We talked about a couple of
these cases, for example,
you can get oscillations just
with negative auto regulation.
And what is it that's necessary?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: High coordination.
PROFESSOR: High coordination?
You me-- oh you're--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Cooperativity in
the repression, that I think
is necessary, but is it
going to be sufficient?
Even in this case where I just
have, let's say that I say,
x dot the rate of production,
if this thing is just
as a function of x, the
sharpest it could be,
this is infinite cooperatively,
so it's maximal expression.
And then when you get above
some x critical all of a sudden
you fully repress.
If I just have this
be the formula--
did you guys understand
what I'm referring to here?
What would this generate?
Would this generate
oscillations?
So it actually doesn't.
In the simple equation,
where if we have x dot
is equal to this function.
So I guess this
is a theta, I want
to make sure I get this
x, less than x critical,
that's what this means.
So with some [INAUDIBLE] rate
beta, minus some alpha x.
Does this thing oscillate?
No, and we had a simple argument
for why did not oscillate,
as well.
Yes?
Yell it out somebody, I'm sure
somebody was here on Thursday.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So this is just--
This is just an x dot,
there's no x double
dot, so that means
the derivative of
x, the single value
is a function of x,
that means that we
can't get any oscillation here.
And then remember we analyzed
this model where we explicitly
included the mRNA, so then
we just had that x comes,
and what it does,
is it represses
expression of this mRNA for x,
and then this mRNA comes back
and makes x.
Right?
And in this model,
was this sufficient?
Did this give oscillations?
No, so this also here,
there was no oscillations.
Again here, there
were no oscillations.
But I did tell you that
you could do something more
to get oscillations, just with
a single protein repressing
itself.
So you need more delays.
So if you add delays, then it's
possible to get oscillations.
So those delays could be in
the form of having a model
where you explicitly take into
account that first mRNA is
made, and then
that goes, and then
you translate that
to make some monomer,
and then the monomer
has to maybe fold,
and then the folded
protein maybe
has to dimerize in order
to do a repression.
So if you have a more detailed
mechanistic model, that
includes all these steps,
that kind of introduces
some sort of delay,
that in principle
can lead to oscillations
in such a circuit.
Or if you wanted to, you could
just explicitly put in a delay.
So you could say
that x dot, instead
being a function of x,
instead what you can do,
is you could say, well its
actually a function of x
at some time, t minus tao.
So instead of having the
rate of production of x
be a function of x, at
that moment in time,
instead it could be a function
of x at some previous time.
Doing that, that's a very
explicit form of delay.
And that can also be used
to generate oscillations
in a simple negative
auto regulatory loop.
These are all different
kind of approaches
for encoding delays into a
model and in various approaches
will give you oscillations.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Question
for the repressilator,
when you say the
period is not tunable,
it's because the mRNA lifeline
is very difficult to--
PROFESSOR: All
right, when we say--
AUDIENCE: --in the
model you can--
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
In the model you can,
in principle-- So
what I mean when I say this is
that in this class of model,
so you could also have,
instead of this repressilator
with three, you have the
so-called pentalator,
where you have five proteins
and each is repressing itself.
So these all have
similar features,
so all have these odd numbers
of proteins going around
and repressing one another.
And so you can write down the
model with seven, if you want.
But in all these cases,
it's not tunable.
What we mean by that is that,
when you tune the frequency,
you in general lose the
amplitude of the oscillation.
So the amplitude will go down.
There was a very
nice paper that was
written in 2008 on
this topic, written
by Jim Ferrell at Stanford.
So I just want to mention this.
So its Ferrell,
at Stanford, this
is a paper in Science
2008, and it's
called Robust Tunable
Biological Oscillations
from Interlinked Positive
and Negative Feedback Loops.
So nice title, I like
titles that say something.
So it's sort of the
ultimate short version
of an abstract, right, if
you can do it I recommend it.
Incidentally in
graduate school, I once
wrote a paper with four words,
short words, DNA over-winds
when stretched.
Nice statement,
you may or may not
actually know what
I mean by that,
but it's a nice short,
title, it's a statement.
I encourage you to
think about that when
you're writing your papers.
So he wrote this paper where,
he said, all right, well,
oscillations are
really important.
Thinking about context of
heart rhythms, or cell cycle,
or this or that.
Oscillations are
important, but if you go
and you look at
the circuits that
are generating
oscillations in biology,
they often have so-called
interlinked positive
and negative feedback loops.
There are many cases
where you have,
some x that actually
is positively,
it's kind of activating itself.
And this is very much
something that will not lead
to oscillations on its own.
It might be bistable,
which is interesting,
but not oscillations on its own.
But then there's also
maybe a negative feedback
loop through another protein.
And the idea is that
this one somehow
operates-- this one's
fast, and this one's slow.
And the key feature of
these relaxation oscillators
is they are two time scales.
And it's the slow
time scale that
specifies the period
of the oscillation,
and this fast one kind
of locks the system
into these alternative states.
And this helps
maintain the amplitude,
because it has this nature
being bistable, right,
so it's on or off.
So this helps you
maintain amplitude,
so this is kind of in
charge of amplitude,
and this one over here is
in charge of the period.
So what you can imagine that
by changing this time scale,
you change the period
of the oscillation,
whereas this loop allows you
to maintain the amplitude.
And what Jim's group did
computationally in this paper,
is they analyzed many
different circuit designs that
can lead to
oscillations, and they
showed that for
the loops that are
made of purely
negative interactions
like this, if you change
a parameter in order
to change the period,
you'll also in general
make the amplitude of the
oscillations drop dramatically.
So that's the sense in
which they're not tunable.
Whereas if you have
this kind of design,
you can actually tune over, in
some cases a very wide range,
but maintain the amplitude
of the oscillation.
And in addition
to being tunable,
these things also end up
being robust in various ways.
The oscillation is maintained
subject to various kinds
of-- If you twiddle with the
parameters, you double this,
you have that, you still
get nice oscillations here,
whereas in those
designs you tend to lose
the oscillations more easily.
So they claim that based
on that, that these
might be more evolvable.
So even in cases where you
don't need to tune the period,
maybe you still end up
evolving towards this design,
just because it's robust
to stochastic fluctuations
in the concentrations
of things, but also it
might be easier to evolve
these sorts of oscillations.
Are there any questions
about the kind of intuition
behind this for now?
There's a nice kind
of circuit analogy
that people often talk about
in the context of this.
So if you imagine you have some
battery, with some voltage, v,
well, we'll say v battery,
some capacitor over here,
but over here you
have something that
will spark at some voltage,
some v t, you get a spark.
Now the question is, well,
what happens over time
if the threshold is
less than v battery?
We maybe should have
a resistor in here.
So the threshold is
less than v battery,
then this can generate
nice oscillations
in the voltage say across
the capacitor as a function
of time, that are tunable.
Because if you plot
as a function of time.
This is the voltage across the
capacitor, where up here we
might have the v, the battery,
here we might have v threshold.
Now in the absence of--
This thing's that's
going to short
periodically, we're
just going to charge
up the capacitor.
So in principle, there's
going to be this standard r, c
time constant, coming up to
here, but before we get there,
we get the spark.
So then we discharge
across here and this drops.
So you get something
that looks like this.
Now you can imagine by changing,
for example, the resistor,
you can change the rate that
this thing, the capacitor,
will charge up.
But the amplitude
of the oscillations
stay constant, because that's
set by the voltage threshold
across this-- where it shorts.
This is capturing this
dynamic of the separation
of time scales.
So there's a slow time
scale, which is this r,
c time constant, and then
there's the rapid time
scale is where this shorts out.
So you can imagine
that this is an example
of an oscillatory
signal that we can
to tune the frequency without
sacrificing the amplitude.
What we've said so far is that
there are engineering analogs
to these sorts of
relaxation oscillators.
We can model various
synthetic circuits,
or we can look at natural
oscillatory networks,
in order to get a sense
of what's going on.
But of course, a major
goal of this kind
of system synthetic
approach to the field,
is that if all this
stuff is really true,
we should be able to build it.
And there's a very nice
demonstration of this,
also in 2008, by
Jeff Hasty's group.
So Jeff Hasty was actually
trained as a high energy
theorist, and then I think
it was during his postdoc,
maybe he switched into
experimental biology.
Went and did his postdoc,
I think, with Jim Collins.
And then eventually now has
his own group doing systems
synthetic biology.
In this paper, it was
a Nature paper in 2008,
it's called A Fast Robust
and Tunable Synthetic Gene
Oscillator.
It's a nice statement, tells
you what he's about to do.
The data here, this is again
using this basic insight
of having both interlinked
positive negative feedback
loops in E. coli.
He demonstrated that he can get
really beautiful oscillations,
in essentially all the cells,
and that they're tunable,
enter n period, by a
factor of three, or four,
or so, by a fair amount.
And indeed as fast
as 13 minutes,
the oscillatory period.
Which is pretty nice, right?
So I encourage you to
check out this paper.
This paper was also
an example of how
it was in principle possible to
get oscillations just by doing
negative auto regulation.
Right, so this was
a case where they
designed a gene network
that they could tune
and had this wonderful property.
But then after they
did that they noticed
that in their model
at least, they
could get oscillations
in some parameter regime,
just by having the negative
auto-regulatory loop.
And as a result of all these
intermediate processes,
of protein maturation,
and so forth, and then
they went and they
constructed that network,
and they showed that that
could also oscillate.
So again this is an example of
the interplay between modeling,
experiment theory,
modeling, And Jeff Hasty
has gone on to write
another several,
really beautiful papers looking
at these sorts of oscillations,
looking at how you can get
synchronization of oscillators,
and you get period
doubling ideas.
It's really a whole string of
wonderful, wonderful papers.
So I encourage you to, if you're
interested in oscillations,
to look at Jeff Hasty's
work over the years.
If you want a quick
introduction to these papers,
I also wrote a news and views
in Nature on these two papers.
So you can read that,
it's only a page.
Although I guess you
won't hear anything
that you haven't
already heard probably.
Any other questions
about this idea
of how we can use both positive
and negative feedback in order
to get some nice
oscillatory properties?
OK, then let's move on.
What did you guys think of
this paper, the Barabasi paper?
Good, bad, difficult, easy?
AUDIENCE: Why does it
have so many citations?
PROFESSOR: Why does it
All right that's
an inter-- and you
should look at how many--
according to Google Scholar,
I haven't checked this year, but
it's probably 20,000 citations.
I mean it's--
AUDIENCE: Is it a cult thing?
PROFESSOR: It's a cult thing.
Well, I don't know.
That might be exaggerating.
AUDIENCE: I mean
it's a nice paper.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So this is interesting, and
I think that the basic answer
is that there are
networks that are
relevant in many, many, many
fields, which they allude to.
And there are many
researchers that
have been excited about
studying those networks
in many, many fields, and many,
many, many of the networks that
are observed in nature or
social science, the web,
everywhere, they have
these power law structures.
And this is the first
clear simple mechanism
to generate it.
My understanding
is that actually
a mathematician decades
before, actually
did demonstrate that
this kind of thing
could be constructed,
that would lead to this,
but that paper doesn't
have 20,000 citations.
I mean like it's a
lot of these things,
you have to be the
right time, right place,
and have the right idea.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I guess my
main thought about the paper
is exactly that, the
interesting thing about it was,
it came out at about the time
that data on large networks
was readily available.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
There's a reason that this paper
was published at this time,
and of course if Barabasi
didn't do it here,
someone else would have
done it a year or two later.
But it was really that the
data were available everywhere,
and we were seeing these
power law distributions,
and it's really crying
out for an explanation.
I think it's-- You know
sometimes people complain,
that they say, oh yeah, you know
I could have come up with this
idea, it's not that deep.
And maybe you could
have, but you didn't.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And also
I'd say that Barabasi
has a record of doing
interesting things,
and being the first to
point out a simple idea.
If you can reliably be
the first to point out
a simple explanation
for important things,
then that's another
kind of genius, right?
I mean-- and it's
the kind of genius
that I aspire to, because I
know that I'm not going to reach
the other kind of genius.
I mean there are some things you
look at, oh well, I would never
be able to do that, right?
And everyone agrees
that that's hard.
But I think that
there is something
about being able to see what
the scientific opportunities are
at a given time,
and you don't have
to come up with a
really complicated model
or proof in order to have
really important impact.
And this paper is
way beyond, in terms
of number of people that
have read it, cited it,
and so forth, it's
way beyond, probably
any other paper you'll
likely read in your life.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just more thoughts.
PROFESSOR: More thoughts.
Yeah, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: I guess,
what's interesting is,
it starts a conversation, so
we can analyze these networks,
and the feature that
works the best [INAUDIBLE]
starts that
conversation, there's
still a lot more that we
can do with it [INAUDIBLE].
I think that's why I like it.
PROFESSOR: That's a totally--
so this is the Barabasi and Reka
Albert.
So Barabasi is a professor
over at Northeastern now,
Reka Albert is a
professor at Penn State,
and I think they've both
gone on to do what, I think,
are really very interesting
things in this network space,
and more generally.
So I you encourage you to
check out what each of them
have been doing over the years.
All right, so this model, what
are the two key ingredients
of this model?
AUDIENCE: Growth and
preferential attachment.
PROFESSOR: Right,
so the two things
you should be able to
recapitulate on an exam
is that there are
two assumptions here,
there's growth, and there's
preferential attachment.
And we'll talk about
the degree to which we
think each of those
things might be necessary,
but what's the key-- Can
somebody be a little more
explicit than what
we've been so far
about what the
key observation is
that we're trying to explain?
AUDIENCE: There are nodes
that, inactive nodes,
that have more edges than you
expect, either by random or--
PROFESSOR: Right.
Perfect, right.
Observation-- So some
nodes have lots of edges.
AUDIENCE: I mean it is
sort of a meta irony
that this paper is
now very widely cited.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Every time
we talk about it--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Indeed it is ironic,
and we'll talk
about how the scaling
of the citation networks
go in a moment.
Right, so some nodes
have lots of edges,
and you want to be
very clear about this,
this is what you're
trying to explain.
So it's a power law
distribution, so in particular,
you quantify this thing.
That the probability
of having k nodes,
or I'm sorry, the probability
that a node has k edges,
falls off as a power law, 1
over k to some power 2, 3, 4.
So the probability of having
k edges, goes as 1 over k
to some power alpha.
Where alpha is maybe between
2 and 4, for a lot of these.
Now it's important
to make sure that you
keep this qualitative
statement in mind,
because it's true that it
falls off, and sort of rapidly.
Right, 1 over k squared, k
cubed, or k to the fourth,
you'd say, oh, that's a
pretty rapid fall off.
Right?
But it's not rapid
compared to what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: --exponent.
Right.
So for these other models then,
it falls off exponentially.
Right?
So even faster.
So it's easy to look at
1 over k to the fourth,
and think, oh, that's
a fast fall off.
We have to remember
that it's slow
compared to some other things.
So in particular, if you look
at the data for real networks,
and you see that the probability
distribution in many cases
goes over orders of magnitude
in terms of this probability.
You think oh,
that's a big range.
And it is a big
range, but the fact
is that you actually see
some nodes with the thousand
ideas or whatnot,
which is something
that you would just never see,
if it were a random network,
or if it were not a power
law distributed network.
And I think that this
is also highlighting
another statement, which is
that a powerful way to make
a difference, for example,
if you're going to write down
a model, or you're
going to do a theory,
is that it's nice if there's
a clear observation that
needs to be explained.
Because you can
always write down
a model of something,
and maybe you'll
find something interesting.
But a way to massively
increase the probability
that you're going to discover
something interesting
is if you already know there's
something interesting there
and that you're
trying to explain it.
And I think that
this is an example
of that, right there, it
was already an observation,
it was already known.
It's not that he was the first
person to make those plots.
There are other plots of
citation networks before.
So Sid Redner, for
example, had already
done some analyses
of citation networks,
he's a theoretical statistical
physicist over at BU,
but just now, I guess, moving
over to the Santa Fe Institute.
But it's not that he
was the first person
to make that
observation, but he knew
there was something interesting
that needed to explained.
So I'd say that
for any of you that
are thinking about doing
theory, or writing down models,
I would say, whenever
possible start
with an interesting observation.
So can somebody-- maybe you
guys could just throw out,
what are some examples
of nodes and edges that
were given there or elsewhere?
AUDIENCE: Web pages and links.
PROFESSOR: Right,
web pages and links.
And is this a directed
or undirected?
AUDIENCE: Directed.
PROFESSOR: So this
is indeed directed.
Some others?
AUDIENCE: Movie
stars and movies.
PROFESSOR: Movie
This one's a funny one, rig--
So movie stars and then this
is like being in a
movie together, right?
So co-starring or so.
Others?
AUDIENCE: Articles
and Citations.
PROFESSOR: Articles
and citations.
And this is again directed, and
this is not directed, right?
And we can maybe even
try to remind ourselves,
this fell off as alpha
was equal to what?
I guess it was 3,
I think they said.
Actors work around
2.3, I guess they said.
The web was 2.1.
Just because it's
a power law doesn't
mean that it's always going
to have the same alpha right?
But for example, what this means
is that for every paper that
has say 200 citations,
there are going
to be roughly 10 papers
that have 100 citations.
If you increase k
by a factor of 2,
you get almost an
order of magnitude
in terms of the
probability distribution.
So this is an
interesting observation,
and where Barabasi
came in and said,
well, what would be a model
that would recapitulate this?
And what are the models that
did not recapitulate it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the Erdos Renyi--
so other models,
there's the E R,
other models, there's
the Erdos Renyi
network, random network,
and that's because here the
degree distribution is peaked
around something and then
falls off exponentially
as you go above that.
And this is actually where
I think the equations are
wrong in this paper.
Because if you look at
the paper, page 510,
where they say the
Erdos Renyi, you
connect the edges
of probability p,
and then they say you get a
poisson distribution, p of k,
where lambda the mean is
something, but then they say,
oh lambda is equal to some
binomial of something of k,
and so forth.
So I think this is all not
true, but rather that you
can approximate the
binomial with a poisson
in the limit of small Ps.
So be aware if you're
looking at that.
I know-- there was
another network that--
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no, no.
I was--
PROFESSOR: So we're
going to spend
a lot of time talking about
probability distributions
in the coming weeks, but I just
wanted to highlight that there,
as far as I tell, that is
not true what they say.
But there was one other
model for a network
that they talk about,
or they mention.
Does anybody--
AUDIENCE: Small world.
PROFESSOR: The so-called
small world network, right?
And this is-- small
world network,
and this is based on a paper by
Strogatz-- Watts and Strogatz,
small world.
That's Watts and
Strogatz, and this
was a paper where they
demonstrated that there
was a very simple mechanism.
Just by rewiring
a network that you
could get this so-called
small world phenomenon.
Where the Kevin Bacon thing,
where you can take any--
You're right, from Kevin Bacon,
and this is actually the actor
network, so you could say,
starting with Kevin Bacon
can you construct
a list of actors
that costarred with
each person that
gets you to any given actor.
And the statement
is that you are
supposed to be able to do
that from a path of six.
So that all the
actors are supposed
to be connected to
Kevin Bacon by six.
Although maybe you
guys don't even
remember who Kevin
Bacon is anymore.
Oh, you do?
OK.
This rule works for anybody so
just insert your favorite actor
into that sentence.
And it's important,
just to mention
that just because something
is a small world network,
does not mean that it has
power law distributions.
It may be the case that
many power law networks also
have this small world
character, and I'd
say maybe even most
of them, because some
of those highly
connected nodes are
going to be useful
for connecting anybody
to anybody else.
But that's not required to
get the small world character.
Any questions about
that statement?
AUDIENCE: So you can go from
this small world statement
to any sort of strong statement
concerning connectivity?
PROFESSOR: Well stron-- I guess
that the strong statement is
that this property does
not imply that property.
AUDIENCE: You're not
saying that the universe is
true [INAUDIBLE]
because it seems
like, at least the
examples we've listed,
ought to be small world.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I agree.
I think that this
small world property,
that's why I saying that,
it's-- What I do not know,
it's whether it would be
possible to construct a power
law distributed network that
does not have the small world
property, but I would say is
that the ones that I'm aware
of would have the small
world property arm.
Any other questions
about where we are?
So there's interesting
properties of networks
that we would like to explain.
And I would say that
what this paper does,
I think kind of convincingly,
is that they demonstrate
that at least this model, and
we'll get into the assumptions,
does lead to a power
law distributed network.
The answer to the
reading questions
about whether both of these
is strictly necessary,
I think was an
interesting one, and I'd
say that this gets into
the wider issue of there's
a observation that
is maybe interesting.
And then we want to
understand why that might be,
and then what you can do is
you can write down a model that
leads to that behavior.
We've already talked about.
Does that prove that the
assumptions of the model
are correct?
No.
In this case, these are
pretty generic features
of lots and lots of the network.
So when you read it
you kind of believe
that this is a
dominant mechanism,
but it very much does not
prove that these are the only,
this is not at all the only way
to get a power law distributed
network.
I'd say that some of the
language in the paper
might kind of lead you to
believe that that is the case,
and I think this is a standard
logical fallacy that we have
to be careful of,
and something I
think that some the language
is a little bit dangerous.
The development of
the power law scaling
the model indicates that growth
and preferential attachment
play an important
role in networ-- I'd
say that it's quite true,
but once again this question
of-- This is
certainly not a proof,
that those assumptions are
relevant for any given network.
Of course, in all of these
cases, the network does grow,
and there is
preferential attachment.
But there are other
things that are also true,
that may be important,
for example,
in determining exactly what
alpha is or in other things.
And I think that as
indicated that there
are other ways of
getting power law
networks without making
the exact assumptions that
are here.
But its, in my
mind, it's probably
a or d dominant mechanism
in a lot of these networks.
I think it's a fine
paper, but just
remember that it doesn't
prove that those are
the only two important things.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just above the
preferential attachments,
I think you mentioned that
you tried different ways,
and only the linearly one was
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR:Troubling.
PROFESSOR: I agree.
I agree.
And what they assume
in the model here
is that the preferential
attachment goes linearly
with the number
of existing edges.
And I would say that
I very much believe
that preferential attachment
is present in all those things,
but I'm sure that if you
go and you measure it
you're not going to
find that its linear
with the number of edges.
It's going to--
actually, I don't
know what you'll find
in each of those cases,
but there's no reason to
believe it has to be linear.
That being said it may
be, the question is
how strong of a deviation
from linearity is there?
And then how sensitive is the
power law behavior to that?
And that's the kind
of thing that I'm
sure that one of the
20,000 papers that
have cited this paper
in the last 15 years
address this issue.
Yeah, but I mean, this is also
why there are so many papers
that have cite-- It's like
you read this paper , like oh,
you know, it would be really
interesting to do this, tha--
and people have been
following that interest.
Let's go and-- I think that
the derivation is a little bit
tricky, and so I think it's
worth just walking through it.
Especially since some
people apparently
couldn't even get the equations,
which is going to be a problem.
Maybe while we're
on this question
of preferential
attachment-- How do
you guys feel about this
question of networks
within, say the
transcriptional network
of E. coli or other cells?
I mean do you think that
these properties are
relevant in the cell or--
So what would growth mean?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So growth
would correspond
to adding a new gene.
Does that ever happen?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Can some given
a possible mechanism
by which a new gene is
added to the genome?
AUDIENCE: Duplication.
PROFESSOR: For example,
duplication is common, right?
eg.
duplication.
So what does this mean for
preferential attachment?
AUDIENCE: --duplicate the
gene and it will probably also
duplicate the promoter
region, which means--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this, I think,
is very interesting.
So duplication,
in general you'll
duplicate both the coding region
makes protein, but also maybe
the promoter region that
specifies the regulation.
So if you imagine
you have some x here
that is-- And we can
remind ourselves,
are both the incoming and
outgoing edges power law
distributed in
transcription networks?
No, I know this was in
the pre-class reading,
but just in case.
So what you find is that some
transcription factors regulate
many genes, but we don't
have any proteins that
are regulated by 200 genes,
so in that sense typically
we have the things
that are regulated,
there's maybe some x1, x2, x3.
And there might be a
few incoming edges,
so the expression a gene
is typically specified
by a few transcription factors.
Whereas some
transcription factors
might have 100 outgoing edges.
So it's the outgoing edges
that are power law distributed,
and the ingoing are closer
to being plus on or so.
So you can imagine that this
guy might have 100 or so,
whereas over here
some y transcription
factor that is just regulating
two genes, say y1, and y2.
Now, question is,
if gene duplication
occurs kind of randomly
throughout the genome,
which transcription
factor x or y
is more likely to have a
target that's duplicated?
AUDIENCE: x.
PROFESSOR: x, all right.
Interestingly, how
does that scale
with the number of targets?
AUDIENCE: Linear?
PROFESSOR: This actually
is linear, right?
So I'd say that gene
duplication does
give growth and
preferential attachment that
is basically linear with
a number of targets.
It's interesting I'd say I
find this kind of observation
quite interesting,
and compelling,
and makes me feel kind
of comfortable about this
as a mechanism for some
of the global properties.
I mean there's no
selection, there's
no way to explain the
interesting network motifs
and so forth here,
but I'd say just
in terms of some
general properties I
think it's interesting.
Of course, once
again not a proof.
Evolution can do whatever
it wants with these gene
duplication events, but also
I would say not everybody
finds this argument
very, very compelling.
But I'd say I think
it's kind of-- I
get a warm fuzzy feeling inside.
AUDIENCE: We're talking
about transcription network,
it's different from the other
networks you were talking about
in that you also lose genes,
and so is there any discussion--
PROFESSOR: Well you know, you
could lose web pages, you can--
AUDIENCE: Are you
losing them nearly as
fast as you're adding them?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I don't know.
I find that lots of links
to my web pages just
disappear over time, and I--
It's a reasonable question.
I don't-- In some of these
you say, oh well right,
so with the web has been
growing a lot recently,
and so then we'd say the birth
dominates over death there.
Where if you talk about genome
sizes along different lineages,
it certainly is not
growing exponentially
the way the web pag--
I think that that's
fair and true,
but we haven't really actually
specified or made clear,
within a model what happens if
you allow for birth and death.
But I think that you
could introduce death
and recapitulate these
behaviors, so it's
not-- I think just because
some nodes disappear,
doesn't mean that
we have to throw
the whole idea out the window.
But in the presence
of evolution this
is all very complicated, right?
So you can't carry
this argument too far.
AUDIENCE: So it's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well
what we're assuming
is that there is some segment of
DNA that's in front of the gene
that specifies--
gives instructions
of when to transcribe the gene.
So the linearity is
really just assuming
that genes have the same rate
of being duplicated on average.
And this is a very
global property,
so I think that it's
kind of roughly--
I would say it's the middle
model that you would use,
if you're had to
write an old model.
AUDIENCE: Is there anything
in looking for evidence
to support [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's an
interesting question.
It's hard to know
what it would even
mean to collect the evidence
to support it in the sense
that-- You're saying along
different evolutionary
lineages, could we say that
it's more likely to grow.
Of course the other thing to
say is that, the rate of death
would also scale linearly.
In the sense that a gene
being stochastically removed
from the genome should
also scale linearly,
so it's not that
you don't actually
then expect there to be
any systematic change.
I mean it's not as
simple as just saying, oh
the number of targets of
a transcription factor
with many targets
should grow faster.
It's really that
the expectation is
that it should be changing
faster because both duplication
and removal would
both be increasing.
So I think the signature is not
totally obvious in that sense.
So how many people
actually tried
to piece this derivation apart?
Anybody?
All right, and were you happy
with it at the end of your--
AUDIENCE: I think that--
PROFESSOR: --permissions?
AUDIENCE: --that I was
a little bit iffy about.
PROFESSOR:There is like a
crux of the climb at the end.
So let's make sure that we can
understand what happened there.
It's worth-- since we
read the paper it's worth
trying to figure it out.
So what we're going to assume
is that we start with m0 nodes.
So they're going to
be here, and the idea
is it doesn't really matter
how we start this thing.
They might start out
being unconnected,
or they might he connected.
But over time the
signature how we start
is not supposed to
be that important.
What we're going to do is
at each time point we're
going to add one more node.
And as we do that we're
going to add m edges as well.
So we then have the number
of, we'll say, nodes,
N, as a function of time, is
going to be equal to what?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR:Right.
This is just going to be--
we're going to start at m0
and we're going to add
1 each time, m0 plus 2.
Number of edges is just going
to be equal to the number
that we add each time
point, times the time.
So here we're assuming
that we start out
with these nodes
being unconnected.
Now we're given the
assumption that there's
preferential attachment,
so that means
that the probability
of connecting
to some i-th node
that has k edges
is going to be k
to the i divided
by the sum over all the edges.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: All right,
so the assumption
is at each time point we add a
new node, let's say this node,
and with that we bring in
some number, n, of new edges.
So this could be 3,
and then we go randomly
to 3 of the existing nodes.
So each time point
we add m edges.
AUDIENCE: How do we necessarily
add them to the new node?
Like [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry I don't
understa-- oh yeah right,
so the assumption is that
the new node is indeed
being connected to-- that
all m edges that we're adding
are to this new node.
So this is the linear
preferential attachment
that we were talking about.
So what we want
to know first, is
how after a node is connected,
how is it that number of edges
will grow over time.
What we know is
that when it's first
added it has it
exactly m edges, right?
But then as new nodes come,
then we'll maybe get some more
and then it'll grow.
And in particular
we want to get--
We're told that it's going
to grow as this differential
equation, so we want
to kind of get to this.
And the way to
think about this is
that, all right well, how is
it that the number of edges
will change at each time
point, so delta k i.
Well the expected
number of edges
that will be attached to
some node, well that's
going to be m,
this is the number
of edges that were attached
by this incoming node,
times this probability of
attaching to this node.
So this is the
probability of k i.
Now this is in one time step.
So this is really a delta k i.
If we want, we could say over
some delta t, which is 1.
So from that standpoint, we
can actually then write it
as differential
equation, where you
say the change in this number
of edges with respect to time
is indeed going to
be equal to m times
this guy here, which
is the number of edges
that that node has at this time,
divided by this sum over all
those edges.
This is just kind of the
expected number of edges
to be added to that
node at each time point.
What does this thing-- What
does that thing equal to?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: --that
equation, because it
seemed like you just wrote
the same equation on the line
above that line.
You just substituted it--
PROFESSOR: I did.
AUDIENCE: OK, but [INAUDIBLE]
wrote it as [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this is
kind of the discrete version
of this differential equation.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah that's right, that's right.
And of course the beginning
could be highly stochastic
but we're just thinking
about in the limit
of if it's deterministic.
What is this thing in
terms of-- from here
this is just a normalization
constant, right?
Because each edge has to
be attached somewhere,
we're assuming it's
linear with respect
to the number of edges
at each node, right?
And that means that
for normalization we
have to divide by the sum over
all those edges, the edges
that each of the
nodes might have.
What is this thing equal to
in terms of something else
that we might have on the board?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: These have edges
with respect to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I guess the question is
this, can we write this?
Where E is a function of time?
Is that correct?
So we're getting some shakes.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it 2E?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's actually 2E.
Because what you notice
here is that this
is the sum over all of the edges
that each of the nodes have.
But each edge is
connecting 2 nodes.
So the sum over all
these edge distributions
is twice the number of edges.
Now I would say as a
physicist, working in biology,
my general attitude is
that a factor of 2 here,
factor of 2 there,
doesn't really matter.
But this factor of 2
actually is relevant
because it ends up determining
the scaling over time.
So not all factors of
2 are created equal,
and this is one that is
worth paying attention to.
Does everyone here
understand why this
is 2 times the number of edges?
k1 is equal to 1, k2 is
equal to 1, number of edges
is equal to 1.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that means we're
in an undirected network,
if we were in a
directed network,
then we would not
have that factor of 2.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So we are indeed
in an undirected,
and I'd say in a
directed network
you have to then be more
careful about what you--
you have to specify
the k's in and k's out.
So actually, already
just by writing
this we've already
assumed it's undirected,
because we haven't
specified what we mean by k.
We're here, but
very conveniently we
already know how
many edges there
are as a function of time.
This is just equal to m times t.
So we get something that's very
convenient ki divided by 2 t.
From here we can solve
the differential equation.
This is what we want to show.
The fact that we're
doing partials
doesn't really matter,
because it's just time here.
So it's really-- so
we have d ki over ki,
is equal to dt over 2t.
This 2, really again,
is going to make
a difference, because when
we go and we integrate,
we get the logs and so forth.
And so we get that ki
as a function of time
is going to grow with
time, with some constant c,
proportionality to the
square root of time.
So if we didn't have the half it
would just be linear with time.
Now how do we know
what c-- in general
how do we get constants
of integration in life?
AUDIENCE: Boundary conditions.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
boundary conditions,
in this case, the
initial condition.
And what is it that we know?
AUDIENCE: ki.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what we know is that
ki, so this i-th node,
when it's added at time ti,
it should be equal to what?
AUDIENCE: m.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's equal to m.
So when it's first
added, at some time ti,
its number of edges
is equal to m.
Because that's what we've
assumed, is that we add a node
and we connect it
randomly and other things,
so it has m edges initially.
So from this kot, this
is then equal to m
times the square root of
t divided by t initial.
Where ti is the time that i-th
node was added to the network.
Are there any questions
about how we got there?
So I think that this is
relatively straightforward.
The part that gets
confusing is this later part
about the probabilities and
keeping everything straight.
And so what Barabasi
did next, is
he said, all right, well,
what we're going to do,
is we're going to talk
about the probability, P.
Now this is an actual honest
to goodness probability.
The big P is actually
a probability,
and that's as compared
to a probability
distribution, little p.
And I'll put in a little curly
here thing, so it's a little p.
This is saying if you want to
get an actual probability here,
then you have to multiply
that probability distribution
times some range delta k.
If you want to know
that the probability
that some node has between
some number and some number
of edges, then you
multiply it by that range.
Right?
Probability distribution,
this is an actual probability.
And as befits an
actual probability,
we're going to say, OK the
probability that the i-th node
has k edges, that are
less than some value k.
And remember this thing is
actually a function of time.
But we have an expression
for ki as a function of time,
it's equal to this.
So we can solve when we show
that this probability is also
the same as this
other probability.
That the i-th node was
added after some time
t that can be written as this.
So this is saying,
the probability
that some random, say i-th
node, has fewer than k edges,
is the same as saying
it's the probability
that the i-th node was
added after some time, t,
which is this thing.
Because the number of
edges will grow over
time for each of these nodes.
Do you understand that kind
of conceptual statement
that was made there?
Yes?
Any questions?
All right, so the probability
that this i-th node was added
after this time, is also of
course 1 minus the probability
that it was added
before that time.
Whereas time, little t
here, this is at the time
that you're actually looking.
So this is saying, oh well, if
little t is 100, for example,
it's saying all right,
at that time point
after I got 100 nodes, we
want to say, all right, what's
the probably that some
random i-th node was
added before this quantity.
And this is just again
some other kind of time,
if you'd like.
I think this is the part that
it is especially kind of weird.
So this is also
equal to this thing.
And I think
reasonable people can
argue about exactly what
you should write here,
but let's figure out the
basic argument first.
So there's this probability
is equal to this thing.
So this statement is really that
at some time t we have how many
nodes?
We have m0 plus t nodes, right?
So this is something here.
And of course there are edges
going around doing things.
And what we want to know
is, what's the probability
if I grab one of
them, we're going
to call that the i-th node.
What's the probability
if I grab one of them
that it was added
before sometime here.
And it's useful to just imagine
this is as just being some time
t, just so that we don't get
confused by all the symbols.
You say, oh well,
that probability
is really just the probability--
well how many nodes total do
we have here, m0 plus t.
How many nodes were there that
were added before this time t?
Well that's going to be t, you
might want to say t plus m0.
There's a question of whether
you include those nodes that
started there or not.
Given the equations that
Barabasi wrote down,
he kind of assumes
that we're only
counting the nodes
that were added later.
So I'd say if you
want, you could either
add an m0 up there,
or get rid of this m0,
depending on what you like.
But broadly there's this idea
that we have this many nodes,
and this many of them were
added for some time t.
And that's how we get this
m squared t over k squared
was just that time t divided
by the total number of nodes.
And this whole discussion
about whether you
count the initial
m0 nodes or not,
it doesn't matter
because we're going
to take the limit as
t goes to infinity,
and that all goes away.
Are there questions about this?
There is something kind of mind
twisting about this argument,
even though we're really just
picking big T objects out
of essentially little t objects,
but somehow something funny
goes on there.
Any questions about that?
AUDIENCE: Could you just go
through the argument one more
time?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
sure, sure Right so
I think that what's confusing
about it is the fact that we're
asking whether the i-th node
was added before some time t.
And this time t is equal
to something that's funny
based on what we've just done.
But it's useful to just
ask, if at time little t
you look at this
network and I ask
you, all right, was it
added before this time,
big T. Let's just
for concreteness
say m0 is equal to--
we start with 10 nodes.
And we say, OK, at time t
equal to 100, I ask you,
what's the probability that if
I grab a random node, what's
the probability it was
added before some time
big T equal 10.
Well you would say,
very roughly actually.
We can say let's actually,
we can even if you'd like,
say we're not going to count--
we're not going to count
those m0 initial nodes.
So we're just going to be
looking at nodes that we
added later, if you'd like.
And then when you would say,
all right well, at time t 100,
we've added 100 nodes.
And I'm asking, if I grab
one of the nodes, what's
the probability that the node I
grab was added in the first 10
time steps.
Well you'd say, it's
going to be 10%,
because there were 10 nodes that
were added before time big T,
and we added 100, so it's really
just this divided by this.
And with the question of
whether you want to include
m0's or not.
So I think that that argument
is surprisingly straightforward,
but somehow it gets
really confusing is
that the time t we're referring
it's depending on the k's
and t's and so forth.
But that's a way
of keeping track
of how are things scaling
as a function of time.
But if you boil the
argument down to this,
then it makes sense,
but then of course
then you look back at this and
you get confused you again.
Which is how I feel every year
when I prepare this lecture,
but I think it all does
make sense if you--
Any questions about this
argument or that argument
or any part of it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the ti's are
very important [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this is just saying that
if I pick some random node,
we're calling it the i-th node.
I'm asking what's the
probability that the time that
was added was before something.
So this is not one
of the variables,
and you'll see the ti
doesn't appear down here.
Because this is just
saying-- I'm asking you,
if I grab some random
node, the i-th node.
I'm asking you,
what's the probability
that it was added before some
other time, which is all this.
And what you can see is that
it's a function of the time
that we look, because
if I go to longer times
you know then indeed this
probability should it go--
What should it do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, but it depends
on k's as well, right?
What do I want to say?
Ultimately what we see here
is that as time goes infinity,
so after a long
time, then we reach
this stationary
distribution where
the base structure
of the network
is not changing anymore.
And that's because there's
a t in both the numerator
and denominator.
So then the only
thing that is left
is this behavior
as a function of k.
And this is really saying
that the probability
that some node was
added before some time,
is kind of the same
as saying that,
well, that you have
a lot of edges.
And that's how we got
here to begin with,
because the nodes that
were added early end up
with a lot of edges.
This is the so-called rich
get richer phenomenon.
So if you're sitting
on a manuscript,
and you're not submitting
it for publication
you should get on it
because the earlier
that it's published the more
citations it's going to get.
But this is saying
that the probability
that some random node has
a small number of edges
is the same as that
the probability
that the node was added late.
And that makes sense,
because if it's added late
it doesn't have very many
edges, hasn't had time to grow.
And then from those
calculations you
get it at this
degree distribution.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So for this
analytical [INAUDIBLE]
we're assuming the links
could be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So we're taking, in principle
it's a discrete problem
and converting it into
a differential equation.
And it's an interesting
question of I
don't know how big of an
error this ends up making,
and of course this
expression doesn't actually
end up having integers.
But this is a way of making
it so that the errors don't
grow or so, right?
I think that it basically works.
If you'd like you could actually
do the simulation with all
the discrete-- I
think that is actually
going to be the stochastic
dynamics that end up
being more relevant than
the integer kind of issue,
but I haven't actually
looked into that though.
Any other questions
about that so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So there's no loss
of edges, no loss of nodes,
strictly verboten.
I spent a lot of
time trying to plan
an upcoming trip to Germany last
night so German is on my mind.
So are we done yet incidentally?
Nearly right?
Because we have--
What we really wanted
is the degree distribution,
not this probability.
So we have to take
a derivative still,
but as t goes to
infinity, regardless
of how you treat the m0's,
actually what we-- maybe we'll
take the derivative first.
So this probability
density is going
to be the derivative
with respect
to k of the actual
probability here.
So we take a derivative,
this one derivative
that nothing happens,
case squared,
it's going to turn
into a k cubed.
So we get 2m squared
t over k cubed,
we still have the t plus m0, but
when we let t go to infinity,
so after this thing has reached
its stationary distribution,
then we end up just getting
2m squared over k cubed.
I just want to be
clear this is to the k.
The key feature here is that
the probability distribution
goes as 1 over k cubed.
What is interesting is that
when I first read the paper
I actually thought
that this exponent here
would be a function
of the linearity
of the preferential attachment.
So I actually-- and of course
they say that it's not true,
but when I was halfway through
the paper I thought, oh well,
if you just let this go
as some power to the beta,
or so, that you would
maybe get something
like this was 2 plus
beta-- I thought
something like that, but
apparently it's not true.
That if you do not have
linear attachment here
then you just don't get
power law distributions.
They suggest other ways
that you could maybe
get different exponents,
which is very relevant given
the fact that different
real networks indeed
have different exponents.
But I'd say that their
proffered explanation, which
is to include directed edges,
feels unsatisfying because not
all networks are directed.
And this network
here is not directed,
it has next exponents
closer to 2.
So you really want to
have other mechanisms.
But this is as we mentioned,
is it's a thriving field
and people have explored
many different aspects
of this problem.
Are there any other questions
about this derivation, how
we got there, how
convincing maybe you
think it should be or not be?
So I want to just spend the
last five minutes of the class
kind of setting up the
discussion of how we should be
searching for network motifs.
In particular there's
a natural question
which is, we have to decide
what the right null model is,
in terms of deciding what the
expected frequency of a network
motif, like a feed
forward loop might be.
So first of all, why is it
that we maybe should not
use an Erdos Renyi network?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Because it's
not very good for handling
directed networks?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you'd say, oh, not
very good-- I can maybe
make-- there's a clear
analog to it-- you could take
a random undirected ER network
and say put arrows randomly
on each-- I mean I think
that there's a natural ER
version of a directed network.
AUDIENCE: There are constraints.
PROFESSOR: Like what?
AUDIENCE: Like when you
[INAUDIBLE] duplication,
you don't randomly
assign the edge.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
OK, so one thing is that it
may be that biologically there
are constraints, but that
should manifest itself somehow.
In the sense that if, you know
all that may be well and good,
it may be true, what
you're saying, but if we go
and we look at a
transcription network,
if it looks like an
ER network, then I
would say it just
doesn't matter.
The fact that there's
microscopic things going on,
I mean if at the end of the day
it looks like an ER network,
then maybe it's
fine anyways, right?
AUDIENCE: Hum.
PROFESSOR: Or maybe not.
You can argue either way.
AUDIENCE: It depends
on what you want.
If a particular
motif occurs a lot
it might be because
it's selected for it,
but it's not what you were--
--it's for some other reason.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So this is an
important point, that I
would say that in
Erdos approach,
he basically says if we
see a network motif more
frequently than we
would expect based
on some null model,
some null network,
then it's kind of
prima facie evidence
that maybe evolution
was selecting
for it for some reason.
And what you're saying is
that it could be there's
a microscopic mechanism
that just leads
to those things happening,
and so it doesn't
have to be selection,
it could be
just due to the mechanistic
processes below.
And I think that's
a fair concern.
And it's related to a lot of
these other things, in that
just for example,
duplication will naturally
lead to something-- if you
start out with x regulating Y,
and Y is duplicated then
now you have x regulating
some Y1 and also some Y2.
And this is the beginnings
of a network motif,
and so it's a reasonable
thing to worry about
but maybe we can correct for
at least a majority of this
by using the proper null model.
At least that would be the hope.
AUDIENCE: Well, that's why
you don't want necessiarilly--
PROFESSOR: OK, that's fair.
But then the question is,
what you null model should we
be using?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you
feel like having
the microscopic constraints
does not necessarily
need to be in the null model.
I feel we can have a null
model but without using
the microscopic constraints
and then just say, oh well
that's another
possibility for why we
might have these divergences.
I don't think they need
to be in the null model.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's just that
then you can't say anything
about evolution.
AUDIENCE: Well fair,
but I don't should
have to-- I don't think
you have to say something
about evolution
afterwards necessarily.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and I
think that this question
about how strongly you can
argue that evolution, selective
or something, and this is a
little bit of a judgment call,
because most of these
evolutionary arguments
are not ironclad,
it's more a matter
of making you feel kind of
comfortable with looking
for what the evolutionary
explanation might have been.
This is just the nature of
looking at historical science,
right?
I mean, you can
speculate about what
would have happened if Napoleon
had done something else,
or whatever.
But it's a speculation.
Of course the hope is
that we can collect
multiple pieces of evidence
that make us more and more
comfortable with it
and in some cases
we can do laboratory
evolution to get more comfort,
but laboratory
evolution doesn't prove
that that's what happened
a million years ago either.
But I'd say it's more the
accumulation of evidence
to make you feel comfortable
with an argument.
But you know, let's first
make sure we understand
what the null model is, and
then on Thursday we'll decide,
well we won't decide,
we'll discuss what we think
that means about evolution.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I think what we
the other part of the appendix
that we read about the
in and out distributions
is important for the null model.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because it seems
to me that the Erdos Renyi
network might be a good model
for the in distributions,
but not for the
out distributions.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And I think this is
really important.
I think that it's clear that
the actual transcription
network of E. coli, for
example, is not well described
as an Erdos Renyi
random network,
but then it does beg the
question of what should we
be using.
And you could say, well, we
just make a power law network,
but then you say,
oh, but there's
the in degree, and
the out degree.
How much do you want
to keep track of that?
And I think that there is
a fairly strong argument
that what you should
do is what they call
this degree preserving network.
In particular what that means is
that you take the real network,
so you take the actual
network that you're
going to be analyzing, and
there is some actual degree
distribution.
So there's 1 node has-- so k1
might be 106, k2 might be 73,
dot, dot, dot, dot, up to
kn which is equal to 1.
And of course I'm
not even talking
about it being directed,
but you do the same thing
with directed.
But then what you do, is
you kind of mix things up.
So you start with a
real network and then
you do something
to randomize it.
And it's a rather
clever scheme, I'm just
going to describe
it briefly here
and then we'll talk more
about it on Thursday.
What you do is you take
all of the actual--
so let's say we have x1, some
x2 and here we have a Y1,
Y2, Y3, now let's say that these
guys are regulating something
like this.
What you do is you take
two edges randomly,
we'll pick this one
that one, and what we do
is we swap the targets.
So what we do is we make
this guy come over here,
and then this one
comes over here.
So now what we do is we erase
this, and we erase this,
now we have a new network,
but intriguingly, the degree
distributions for both
incoming and outgoing edges
are identical to what
we had before this.
Every guy has the outgoing
edges, incoming edges,
but they're just
different targets.
So if you just do
this procedure many,
many times then
what you do is you
achieve some randomized
version of the real network.
And then what you can do is you
can ask how many feed forward
loops are there.
How many, this, that--
And so there's a fair
argument that this
is in some ways the
proper null model
to be asking the question in.
And indeed, for
example, there are
many more feed forward loops
than there would be in an Erdos
Renyi, but still what you see is
that you lose many feed forward
loop.
So this then the
argument for feed
forward loops
being selected for.
We'll talk about this and
we'll quantify it on Thursday,
but I'm available for
the next half hour
if anybody has any questions.